[Applause]
well done
happy Thursday everybody
so is it all just pretend or have they
met Little Green Men well it looks like
Mulder and Scully were right and I don't
even know who that is but some nerd on
my staff wrote it so let's go with it
yeah According to some remarkable
testimony from three men we heard before
Congress yesterday we are not alone
there are flying saucers and not just
when my assistant screws up my coffee
visited by beings from another world and
it's not just this freak
[Laughter]
we call them UFOs but the government
government now calls them unidentified
anomalous phenomena or UAP not to be
confused with WAP
or a-l-f
the star was David grush a former Intel
officer for the National geospatial
Intelligence Agency
he made headlines last month when he
claimed the U.S government has been
hiding UFO crash debris and even dead
non-human Pilots they're likely in Joe's
Garage next to the Corvette
but this time he said it under oath and
he's not a Democrat so it matters
play the tape
if you believe we have crashed craft uh
stated earlier do we have the bodies of
the pilots who piloted this craft
biologics came with some of these
recoveries yeah
um
were they I guess human or non-human
biologics
non-human and that was the assessment of
people with direct knowledge on the
program I talked to that are currently
still on the program
so they're aliens but they're dead guess
they probably killed themselves when
they learned I was married
it happens a lot
so what does a biologic look like well
we don't know but they're considered
non-human so let's start there
remember that creature
he was here on Earth for a few years
then disappeared I'm pretty sure he was
from the planet jackass
so is gresh credible here's what our guy
Walter Kern said on the show last week
I know the Whistleblower I know Dave
groosh he's actually a very sincere guy
America though may get its wish it may
see a congressional hearing at which all
our big shots are there arranged behind
their desks with their glasses of ice
water and they out the existence of
aliens and suddenly a blue blue beam
comes into the room vaporizes Chuck
Schumer Etc
hmm
so he predicted a lot of that is he
right there I mean people are starting
to act really weird could aliens be
responsible for this Behavior
I love Hot Dogs uh I love them in buns I
love them outside of buns I love them
with baked beans I just like hot dogs
it's the best you know best meat there
is without question he's on the naughty
step from PNC he's not gone on the tour
of Japan
Sean I am telling you getting it right
right at the back there is not real
and you can sit on this plane and you
can die with him or not I'm not going to
this wig has been good by bars in
cooperation
and a string of uh
anything else you want to say I'm sure
let's go back to you
do you want to say anything else to the
Press
Edward Kern was talking about
so why isn't all this testimony a bigger
news story an ex-government official
said we have alien bodies that's either
the greatest story in human history or
the greatest hoax we've had Decades of
sci-fi movies made about this very
moment and we're all like yeah cool
let's watch Barbie
is everyone is checked out as Joe Biden
I mean if there's even a chance it could
be true this is under oath after all why
isn't it the only thing anybody is
talking about today people flip out
every time Kim Kardashian takes out her
garbage
but aliens are real and we're ignoring
it like it's Brian Kilmeade weeping in
the men's room
which is often we finally got several
credible ex-witnesses testifying in an
open Congressional hearing to the
existence of UFOs both the Dems and
Republicans take it seriously too and
everybody just yawns like someone's
showing them pictures of their ugly kids
it's weird maybe if we cared more and
demanded more we'd get more instead we
just shrug off the possibility of
intelligent life from outer space Have
We Become that bored I mean what do we
do after we hear about aliens we go back
to our phones meanwhile gross or
whatever his name is claims people have
been injured in efforts to cover up this
technology I think we call that the
coven vaccine mandate
do you have any personal knowledge of
people have been harmed or injured in
efforts to cover up or conceal these
extraterrestrial technology yes anyone
been murdered that you would think that
you know of or have heard of I guess I
have to be careful asking that question
I directed people with that knowledge to
the appropriate authorities so it seems
all of this is worth more than a few
minutes on a talk show especially since
UAP are in our airspace but they're
grossly underreported
UAP are in our airspace but they are
grossly underreported these sightings
are not rare or isolated they are
routine are there common characteristics
to the uaps that have been cited by
different pilots and can you describe
what the convergence of descriptions is
certainly we were primarily seeing dark
gray or black cubes inside of a clear
sphere I'm sorry dark gray or black
cubes yes inside of a clear sphere where
the Apex or tips of the cube were
touching the inside of that sphere it's
basically a circle full of black squares
sounds intriguing how does that stay in
the air actually is it some sort of
anti-gravity device or perhaps one of
our own experimental aircrafts flying
through the air like that you know it
could be one of our trains
maybe it's the machine they use to lower
Joy Behar into her pants
[Laughter]
ex-navy pilot when asked about his 2004
encounter with a UFO
based off of each of your experiences
and observations do you believe uaps
pose a Potential Threat to our national
security yes and here's why
the the technology that we faced was far
superior than anything that we had
and you could put that anywhere if you
if you had one you captured one you
reverse engineered it you got it to work
you're talking something can go into
space go someplace drop down in a matter
of seconds do whatever it wants and
leave
and there's nothing we can do about it
sounds like he's describing me at a
Starbucks bathroom
okay
but we can't let flight technology fall
into the wrong hands like the Russians
or Worse Spirit Air
anyway these guys all served our country
for decades and no one at the hearing
questions their credibility so perhaps
the government knows more about this
stuff than they've been letting on I
mean if they'll cover up cocaine in the
white house why wouldn't they cover up
extraterrestrial Pilots at Area 51 or
maybe I got it backwards and the story
is being Amplified on purpose as a
distraction for something else
but allegedly this has been happening
for decades without the general public
knowing how is that possible
do you have knowledge or do you have
reason to believe that there are
programs in the advanced Tech space that
are unsanctioned
uh yes I do how does a program like that
get funded
I will give you generalities I can get
very specific in a closed session uh but
a misappropriation of funds and uh does
that mean does that mean that there is
money in the budget that is said to go
to a program but it doesn't and it goes
to something else yes I have specific
knowledge of that yep that seems like
you need to follow a question for that
so maybe we're not alone should we be
scared I mean Sci-Fi movies always
showed our cities getting destroyed by
aliens but let's be honest the Dems are
doing a far better job than any green
man ever could
so of any beings from other planets are
watching this right now here's my
question why why the anal probes
and more importantly do you clean them
afterward
[Applause]
s like a Hallmark movie she was made for
TV Fox Nation host Casey McDonald Hosmer
toads get high from licking her Fox News
contributor tattoo
and the Kool-Aid man once asked him for
tips on how to bust through walls my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion tyrants
so
Andrew I've been following I feel like
such a news man after doing that all
those clips watch out Bret bear huh it's
easier than it looks you know
um whenever you hear these stories it's
only like in America which means is
Britain just too boring yeah the aliens
never come to me I don't know why I'm a
bit jealous actually but I've always
believed in owners I I genuinely think
that because how else could you explain
Barry Manilow right but I think what but
why I don't believe you guys when you're
talking about aliens now is that you
constantly talk about the wreckage that
the government has yeah or the wreckage
that you've got why did the aliens keep
crashing right because we're supposed to
believe that these people have mastered
interdimensional travel but they can't
park yeah that's true have they only
sent their women aliens oh
sexist would say you I was just about to
say that all right well there we go
great minds yeah although this could be
a great political opportunity I think
like with Donald Trump you know he won
in 2016 by starting to build a wall to
keep out Mexicans yeah and we could
build a dome yeah he's going to keep ban
aliens yeah that's true that's true they
might be here right now now and just be
invisible that's what I worry about
Casey have you ever dated an alien
probably yeah we aren't we in a dome
though if you believe in aliens we are
in a dome right yeah we're already in
one there's water above us I'm dressed
as I knew the aliens existed all along
Barbie today
um I do believe in aliens absolutely I'm
I'm so in the prepper space now you
should see my Tic Tac when I open it up
it is all that stuff but I think the
powers that be they were like they
really want the Epstein log give them
the aliens just throw the aliens best we
can do are aliens well that's true I
mean there is the idea that it might be
a distraction except though it's like
the Republicans are into it too so well
the Epstein log would explain that
because that's kind of bipartisan
perversion I think I would know I don't
participate in that sort of garbage cat
what's up I don't know you've often been
mistaken for a space alien because you
have a freakishly small body and a large
head with lifeless eyes
so glad I came to work
I think you wrote that question I did
not
[Laughter]
so what do you think I think that
actually what you were saying earlier
explains it all you said that both sides
are interested in it that's why we don't
talk about it more because there's no
political advantage to talking about
aliens right now if we find out there's
aliens there's no way that the
government can do it but if they found
out the aliens were woke yeah
boom yeah that's the problem I don't
want the identity group to deal with but
they don't know it that's the only issue
they don't know enough about the aliens
to know how to politicize it yet oh they
do there's nothing more otherness than
being an alien from another planet
that's the thing and you know they're
gonna be like the woke you know they're
gonna be like they're going to come down
here take over everything and then act
like they're oppressed well maybe that's
why they're all dead yes oh right yeah
maybe I might identify as one just to
get the perks right maybe they're not
woke though maybe they're really really
like libertarian and they don't still
want they're here they don't want to let
anyone know because they don't want to
pay taxes and they love cats too
the moment aliens land they're going to
want to pay taxes yeah I wouldn't tell
anybody I want you you're the government
made me yeah Taurus why does no one care
like even now okay that's pretty
compelling stuff this
but I feel like if someone has to wait
for the government to tell you that they
were aliens on this planet you're
already a to begin with yeah like
if you vacationed if you've been to
anywhere in a Temple You've seen a
pyramid they're all over the world they
even that you can tell by the designs
that it was not 16 slaves in Iraq that
built the pyramids yeah perfect designs
we still can't do today listen for 70
000 years we had a rock and a stick and
couldn't figure it out somebody came
down to here tie this together build
this stuff try to use some fire and then
what happened we round and ate them or
sexually assaulted them and they left
yeah the reason why they drive back is
because they're like Elon got Rockets
going they're like someone needs to
swing by and make sure they can't get up
here yeah remember the last time
last time we went down there
[Applause]
the same thing the Angels come down
right right but you never hear about
them going back right because they look
around and ran into a human being and we
either ate them fought them or
you know
so they left do you think we only find
the dead ones because they rather die
yeah and spend one day here it is an
interesting fact though if we eat fellow
earthlings we've talked about this we
eat cows and pigs and Ducks those are
earthlings why why what should prevent
us from eating if you just pulled up to
a spawn like hey this is a good place
let's check it out let's take this to
the leader they are eating everybody
yeah
I'm small I have no bone density I can't
breathe this oxygen
mystery of them in all of mankind
getting the way we are and how we were
able to become the way we are it's just
that we ruined the teacher the teachers
left and then our technology is a dumber
version of theirs because they took all
this with them like nope they cannot get
up here no
I would do the same thing I think hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else